this is where Sir Philip green usually
comes for the good of his health social
reaction you're not understanding go
away so Philip what do you think about
Lord hain and what he did in Parliament
this week this is the first time the
billionaire has been seen in public
since allegations surfaced this week
will you respond to those who's made
accusations to Philip can you go away go
away do you not believe that those
who've made accusations deserve a
response those who made accusations to
Philip will feel they deserve a response
so you're not going to give that to them
you try to run me over Sir Philip no
look like it sir he did then reverse and
told us quite calmly that for legal
reasons he couldn't comment even if he
wanted to but declined to say that on
camera he is thousands of miles from
Westminster where the former Labour
Minister Lord Haines used parliamentary
privilege to identify him I feel it's my
duty under parliamentary privilege to
name Philip green as the individual in
question in connection with the Daily
Telegraph's claims that an unnamed
businessman had been granted an
injunction preventing them from
reporting allegations of sexual
harassment and abuse of staff in a
statement sir Philips said that to the
extent that it is suggested I've been
guilty of unlawful sexual or racist
behavior I categorically and wholly deny
these allegations for one of Britain's
most high-profile tycoons this isn't the
first time in an uncomfortable spotlight
his part in the sale of BHS and the
pension scheme left behind brought
widespread criticism there are now
renewed calls for his knighthood to be
taken away the initial award was highly
controversial because of his tax affairs
and he narrowly escaped being stripped
of his knighthood because of the
pensioners debacle and if the facts
surround this recent
non-disclosure agreement are indeed
established I think it would be
impossible to see how the committee
which is informed by the Prime Minister
could do any other understanding
it isn't clear when Sir Philip will
leave the Arizona Sun and return to the
UK but the questions will be waiting to
meet him there - Greg Milam Sky News
Tucson in Arizona